du coup ils auront traversé une partie
de la loire jusqu'aux bancs de sable et
ils ont marché dessus et puis d'un seul
coup comme il ya des trous dans la loire
bain le jeune homme est tombé dans un
trou ne sachant pas il savait pas nager
donc ben elle suit la panique s'est noyé
on voit les deux copains nous appeler au
loin donc bah ce que je fais pour mon
téléphone j'appelle les pompiers et au
même moment les copains il plonge dans
l'eau pour aller essayer de le récupérer
j'ai plongé avec deux autres amis en
fait j'ai essayé de chercher à leurs
copains qui s'étaient noyés j'ai pas
réussi en fait avoir tellement c'était
profondément que la loire ça brasse et
c'est donc impossible du coup de
retrouver ce enfin soffritti gamin bas
on l'a pas trouvée vu qu'il était à une
profondeur de 5 mètres et on a attendu
les pompiers arrivent pour bat que pour
rappel le relais quoi
ce que je veux dire aux gens c'est quand
vous baigner à la rigueur n'allaient pas
un endroit que vous ne connaissez pas
quand vous êtes plus pied ça peut être
aussi dangereux que les courants donc
rester au bord de l'eau si vous savez
pas nager banal et pas dans l'eau ça je
déconseille et si vous voulez aller dans
le il y avait aussi à 2,3 personnes
jamais tout seul et surtout ne pas
essayer de nager ou traverser la loire
rester au bord se baigner se tromper ça
suffit largement